most people realize that we are in deep
we hear a lot about the urgent need to
get off fossil fuels I will do
everything in my power to win the Clean
Energy Future so how are things going on
this front we're at this incredible
inflection point the Russian invasion of
Ukraine has transformed the energy
landscape in ways you might not expect
somebody asked me what is a wind
generator sound like and I said it
sounds like money to me what's stopping
the global energy Supply from going
fully green show me this Frankenstein of
a car you got here and how fast is the
world moving towards this
[Music]
goal it's 8 in the morning and the
climate campaign group last generation
is preparing for another
protest these activists call themselves
the last generation who can stop climate
collapse
German authorities like so many others
around the world have declared policies
to reach Net Zero by the middle of the
century but these protesters are deeply
frustrated by the pace of change away
from fossil fuels to clean
energy today their target is blocking
one of NE B's busiest
roads and the group manages to shut it
down for 45
minutes these kinds of tactics aren't
popular with
many but the protesters insist they will
not be deterred we managed to bring our
peaceful protest onto the road we will
not get stopped by the police by higher
repressions or anything
else the group is part of a network of
climate protesters using similar tactics
to make their message stick they've
glued themselves to
robes thrown fake oil over a
climp and mashed potato at a
mono we need to get off fossil Resources
by 2030 there's no negotiation we need
to get off by then not
2045 as our government proposes right
now we waited way too long and this is a
death sentence to
society so as leaders respond to climate
change is the world moving fast enough
towards clean secure
[Applause]
energy climate activists say things have
been made worse by the global energy
crisis
the Russian invasion of Ukraine
presented a historic opportunity for
green change but campaigners insist
Europe failed to grasp it until Russia
turned off the Taps it supplied Europe
with more than 40% of its imported gas
and about a quarter of its oil and yet
to plug this Gap governments across
Europe turned back to fossil fuels to
keep the lights on the government right
now they are fueling the crisis by still
sub subsidizing fossil fuels by
extracting more oil more
gas in January 2023 the German Village
of lerat grabbed Global headlines with
the mass occupation of a site where the
government gave permission to expand a
coal mine you are the change and you are
the
hope the fact green party ministers also
backed the plant only fueled
anger
it really encapsulated some of the
tensions that governments faced in
reacting to Russia's Invasion which was
a desperate time and governments took
desperate and controversial measures
governments turned to fossil fuels in
the immediate aftermath for a very
simple reason which was that they were
available for the fossil fuel companies
it was boom time again you saw this big
spike particularly in oil and gas prices
extraordinary to see the levels uh that
we're getting for that wholesale gas
price another day another petrol price
record oil prices in June of 2022
climbed above $120 a barrel and then in
natural gas the rise was even more
extreme so in August of 2022 prices were
about 10 times as high as they had been
in the Years leading up to the invasion
even coal the dirtiest fossil fuel of
all enjoyed profits many thought had
long gone after it seemed to Peak in
2013 Global consumption in 2022 P 8
billion tons for the first time in
history so does this mean the world will
never find the will to shift to Green
energy fast
[Music]
enough well not necessarily so you'd
think hearing all of this that it has
been a dire time for the energy
transition in the immediate aftermath of
the invasion it seemed like the energy
transition might slow down as
governments turn to coal and natural gas
but what we've seen instead is a real
acceleration in investment in sources of
green
energy in 2022 globally installations of
rooftop solar panels Rose by half with
investment in solar and wind growing
from 357 billion
to 490 billion exceeding investment in
oil and gas Wells for the first time and
in 2023 it's predicted that total
investment in clean energy will hit $1.8
trillion compared with 1 trillion for
fossil fuels Vladimir Putin's energy
threat to the West seems to have
backfired the war in Ukraine may have
fast-tracked the global transition to
Green energy by as much as 5 to 10 years
by sending fossil fuel prices soaring
Russia made Renewable Power look more
appealing than ever oil and gas became
really expensive and so other forms of
energy look increasingly attractive
particularly in the long term and then
governments are really interested in
energy security particularly domestic
sources of clean energy uh because of
this growing concern of overdependence
on hostile government diversifying a way
from Russia for fossil fuels and massive
investment in renewable energy
around the world regions and governments
have announced significant Investments
and
Partnerships the inflation reduction Act
was the biggest step forward on climate
ever ever creating new green
manufacturing hubs and jobs in unlikely
places one of the remarkable things
about recent years in the energy
transition is you see parts of the world
that formerly were dedicated to fossil
fuels becoming something entirely
different and there's no place where the
this is more evident than the North Sea
because it's an absolutely enormous
resource of wind and it's relatively
shallow which makes it easier to put in
big turbines in England Hull has become
a manufacturing site to help put these
giant turbines together governments
around the world want to create jobs and
generate
votes although new green policies are
accelerating big new Investments it's
not clear that politicians Promises of
green jobs will bear fruit Ro at
scale so what more needs to be done to
get to Net Zero and is it being done for
a start major bottlenecks in bureaucracy
and infrastructure need to be eased to
allow the new wave of Renewables to plug
[Music]
in it's a phenomenal construction
project and invisible to most people
deep beneath the Streets of London
that's exactly what Alice DEA Hunty is
working on so we're about 30 M below the
surface here and this train is
transporting the spoil from what's come
out of the tunnel Boring Machine she is
overseeing a 1 billion pound project to
rewire South London with a new 32 km
underground tunnel so this is the forest
air circulation down in the tunnel so so
we have good air to breathe this
makeover is essential if London's grid
is going to cope with a surge in green
energy Supply it's a huge project 7-year
construction project deep under London
basically to rewire it so to replace
what were aged cables with bigger higher
capacity cables so it's future proofing
the city against electrification of
Transport growing electrification need
um quietly just going on under the roads
of the city without people realizing but
this is just one wire on a much bigger
Global circuit board and as wind and
solar Farms shoot up and fossil fuel
power stations scale
down long cues to connect to the grid
are leaving green energy operators short
fused to add to the challenge by 2050
the world will need to generate much
more electricity than it does today to
hit climate goals including more than
double to hit Net
Zero now we're at this incredible
inflection point where we have to
completely reconfigure the grids to
accommodate renewable energy and to make
the clean energy
[Music]
transition more grid connections and
less red tape could help speed up the
global move to Green energy by
25% new ways are also needed to store
the energy generated by Renewables and
to share it connecting into other
countries plays a really uh crucial role
as well because that means we can share
our energy so when the wind is blowing
here but there's more energy needed in
Denmark we can send it that way and vice
versa to do that more grids will need to
be knitted together by cables known as
interconnections they are incredible
Feats of engineering um they are laying
these high voltage direct current cables
all the way through the sea and they
land at either end in what are called
converter stations which are almost
sci-fi like pieces of equipment that
turn that electricity back from direct
current into alternating current which
is uh what we use in our homes buildings
hospitals and businesses so they're a
really key part of the energy
transition Innovations like these could
help roll out more renewable energy but
as the sun doesn't always shine and the
wind doesn't always blow the world will
also need new sources of clean
power the power of the atom or old ones
greatest source of energy man has ever
discovered nuclear power which went out
of fashion decades ago is now hoping for
a
makeover in places like the Bristol
Channel where Britain's first new
nuclear power plant in 30 years is
taking shape 10,000 people are working
around the clock to get Hinkley Point C
ready to switch on in 2026 you can see
we've got 52 cranes on site and Big Carl
is the biggest crane in the world and
Tam alawi is its commissioning director
we're building this power station so
that we are able to generate 7% of the
UK's Power by
2027 nuclear power produces hardly any
carbon emissions and unlike wind or
solar can run 24/7 to give grids the
consistent base load they need with the
recent push for energy security across
the globe there are now fresh eyes on
nuclear power the energy crisis and the
war in Ukraine have had a real impact on
the perception of nuclear power and it
has highlighted The Importance of Being
energy independent having the ability to
build our own power stations will enable
us to have that energy
Independence nuclear power is much safer
than energy produced by fossil fuels and
even wind turbines but like many nuclear
projects Hinkley is over budget and
behind schedule nuclear's unpopularity
High upfront costs and long build times
mean that the technology has gone Rusty
in Western countries and that's
challenging for the clean energy
transformation having not built
something for a long time we're having
to develop and establish the capability
in Britain that includes the supply
chain and includes our people to be able
to deal with all the challenges of
construction of a massive Mega scale
project like inly Point C part of that
is leveraging some of the experience
from other countries so in China for ex
example they are building power stations
more
frequently if the world is to get off
fossil fuels one thing needs to happen
for
sure the Alternatives can't just do good
for the planet they need to make good
money too and there's one place where
the tycoons have always known how to get
the most bang for their
[Music]
buck in the Heart of Texas green jobs
are booming the traditionally
conservative state is leading the way
for renewable energy across the nation
the lanar state might not be the obvious
place to find a boom in Green Tech but
these days cattle generate $8 per acre
here compared with hundreds from wind
turbines somebody asked me what is a
wind generator sound like and I said it
sounds like money to me Texas is a
staunchly Republican state where many
remain skeptical about climate change
yet hard economics is transforming
another big business traditionally
linked to fossil fuels if we can bring
the modern technology into these older
vehicles it really lets you appreciate
them and continue to use them into the
future Kevin Emma's company is giving
classic American Muscle Cars a new lease
of Life by converting them to Electric
technology although these converted
classic cars form a niche end of the
market he's hoping to capitalize on The
Wider boom in electric vehicles the
process is disassemble the vehicle
reassemble the vehicle with all the
electrical components then spent a heck
of a lot of time wiring it all up and
and then lastly uh getting it dialed in
and tuned which is what we're doing
today
8.32 perfect they've been working on
this replica 1965 Shelby Cobra for the
last 6
months and now it's finally time for
rubber to meet
Road
this is actually our first ecobra that
we'll be testing it hitting the streets
with the car has passed all of its tests
and we're ready to rock and
roll EVS especially bespoke models like
these are not in the budget for
most
ni however sales of EVS have been
turbocharged by the benefits they offer
in fuel costs and convenience all
[Music]
right it's very very convenient to
charge your car at home and it's also
very cost effective it's less than a
third give or take on the cost to fill
up a car with electricity than it is
fill it up with gasoline the effect of
that is is a much Greener
solution but not everyone around here is
happy to do away with petrol show me
this Frankenstein of a car you got here
old attitudes die hard I grew up in the
muscle car era in 65 to 68 in high
school if you wanted a hot good-look
chick you needed a hot good-look car it
was just that simple continued growth in
the EV Market is Central to a green
future and here the numbers are
encouraging by 2025 EVS will make up a
quarter of new car sales globally
putting a total of 77 million EVS on the
road this figure is set to rise to over
700 million in 2040 when an estimated 34
of new car sales will be electric to get
there car makers around the world will
invest $1.2 trillion by
2030 what's really interesting in recent
years is the surge in money going to
electrified transport which is now about
as large as as the level of capit
Capital going to wind and solar and so
for a long time green cars electric cars
were something that investors were
excited about but hadn't really hit the
mainstream and now that's
changed but there are hazard signs ahead
EVS need batteries and batteries need
lithium the boom has thrown up
environmental concerns about lithium
mining in places such as the atakama
desert in Chile in the broader picture
the world's transition to clean energy
could stall without the crucial minerals
required to boost the transformation to
Green energy some environmentalists will
probably have to change their
perspective historically
environmentalists have specialized in
not building stuff so preventing
companies from coming in and ruining for
example a stretch of pristine Wilderness
now the climate movement has to be about
building stuff that includes building
things in areas that historically an
environmentalist might have wanted to
protect like a desert it includes big
investments in mining which remain Emi
of Industries but you need those uh
resources in order to speed the
transition towards green
[Music]
energy and this is just one of many
changes required to power the world
towards the promised land of fully green
energy a journey that is still only just
starting so you have seen this enormous
surge of investment in America in Europe
in China in India this is all promising
it's also not at the scale required and
it's late the world is already warming
so this is both a hopeful story because
there's lots of action and a reminder
that much more needs to be
[Music]
done hi I'm Charlotte Howard executive
editor at The Economist if you'd like to
read more about the energy transition
please click on the link opposite and if
you'd like to watch more of our now and
next series please click on the other
link thanks for watching and don't
forget to
subscribe